[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halbweg guten Abend und
willkommen in allen an diesem Freitag
Christian otto ist auch dabei für den
Sport viel los bei uns guten Abend und
das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
mutige Kämpfer für die Freiheit den
Friedensnobelpreis teilen sich
Menschenrechtler aus Belarus Russland
und der Ukraine
Strategien gegen hohe Energiepreise die
EU-Staaten sind uneins über einen
gaspreisdeckel
authentisch kantig bodenständig der
Schauspieler Günter Lamprecht stirbt im
Alter von 92 Jahren
[Musik]
wir beginnen mit dem deutlichen Zeichen
aus Oslo in Zeiten des Krieges drei
Friedensnobelpreisträger kürt das
Komitee in diesem Jahr alle drei Kämpfen
gegen Machtmissbrauch der Inhaftierte
belarussische
aktivistki die verbotene russische
Menschenrechtsorganisation Memorial und
das Zentrum für bürgerliche Freiheiten
in der Ukraine Lena sünderbruch stellt
sie vor
sie seien herausragende Vorkämpfer für
Menschenrechte Demokratie und friedliche
Koexistenz so würdig das Nobelkomitee
die Arbeit der drei Preisträger da ist
zum einen der belarussische Politiker
und Menschenrechtsanwalt aliaski er
sitzt in seiner Heimat im Gefängnis wie
aliatzki gehört zu den Mitbegründern von
viasna einer der wichtigsten
Nichtregierungsorganisationen des Landes
sie dokumentiert
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und
beobachtet Wahlen spielt eine wichtige
Rolle in der Demokratiebewegung
besonders zur Zeit der Proteste gegen
Machthaber Lukaschenko auf diese Arbeit
angesprochen sagte er vor zwei Jahren
ich bin nicht der Auffassung dass wir
irgendein Vorreiter ein Flaggschiff
dieser Veränderungen sind wir leisten
unseren kleinen Teil dieser Arbeit zur
Veränderung
ebenfalls gewürdigt die
älteste russische
Menschenrechtsorganisationen Memorial
ein russisches Gericht hatte sie im
Dezember aufgelöst trotzdem versuchen
Mitstreiter die Arbeit vorzuführen sie
setzen sich unter anderem für die
Aufarbeitung der stalinistischen
Verbrechen in der Sowjetunion ein das
ist sehr unerwartet aber die Freude
darüber ist natürlich groß und es
bedeutet das was wir tun ist nicht
vergebens
auch beim dritten Preisträger setzt das
Komitee ein klares politisches Zeichen
das Zentrum für bürgerliche Freiheiten
leistet ganz ähnliche Arbeit aber in der
Ukraine es ist seit dem russischen
Angriff auf das Land zum Beispiel daran
beteiligt russische Kriegsverbrechen
gegen die Zivilbevölkerung zu
dokumentieren
wir erreichen die Leiterin des Zentrums
Alexandra romanzova am Bahnsteig während
einer Reise es ist wichtig dass die
Ukraine das Gefühl hat dass die ganze
Welt auf sie schaut dass die ganze Welt
sie unterstützt mit der Preisvergabe
will das Nobelkomitee aus Oslo das
Signal senden die Zivilgesellschaft ist
das effektivste Mittel gegen Krieg und
Autoritarismus
manche meinen diese Friedensnobelpreis
sei ein vergiftetes Geburtstagsgeschenk
an Wladimir Putin der russische
Präsident wird heute 70 und lud nach St
Petersburg im Palast im Finger die Chefs
früherer Sowjetrepubliken offiziell zu
einem Arbeitsbesuch erforderte eine
engere Zusammenarbeit und die Lösung von
Konflikten zwischen den ex-republiken
westliche Beobachter werden das Treffen
als Versuch Putins von seiner
internationalen Isolation abzulenken
wie es Russen ergeht die den Dienst in
Putins Krieg verweigern und in
Deutschland Schutz suchen dazu gleich
ein ZDF heute live um 19 Uhr in unserer
App und auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
für oder gegen Russland auch in den
besetzten Gebieten der Ukraine mussten
sich viele Menschen entscheiden manche
schlugen sich auf die russische Seite
auch in Orten die inzwischen von den
Ukrainern zurückerobert wurden wie
schwierig das für alle Beteiligten ist
hat unsere Reporterin Katrin Eigendorf
im Dorf kazacha loparden beobachtet dort
war sie mit dem ukrainischen Militär
unterwegs
am Bahnhof von kazacha lopern weht
wieder die ukrainische Flagge doch nicht
alle Einwohner in dem kleinen Ort an der
russischen Grenze sehen die Ukraine als
Befreier erzählen uns die Soldaten der
Nationalgarde die uns durch die Straßen
führen
es gibt die die nicht besonders freudig
sind und diejenigen die die sogenannte
russische Welt unterstützen wir Filtern
diese Menschen heraus und übergeben Sie
dem Sicherheitsdienst der Ukraine
die Soldaten nehmen uns mit in eine
Lagerhalle auf dem Boden sind Fesseln
zurückgeblieben hier sollen die Russen
ihre Verhöre durchgeführt und Menschen
gefoltert haben darunter auch lokale
Politiker in der Stadtverwaltung treffen
wir die Ortsvorsteherin die die mit den
Russen zusammengearbeitet hätten sein
fast alle geflohen erzählt sie uns
die Russen haben einigen von ihnen Angst
gemacht sie haben ihnen gesagt die
ukrainischen Soldaten würden sie
aufschlitzen und ihnen alles mögliche
antun
wie angespannt die Situation ist erleben
wir kurz darauf ein Ermittler der
Staatsanwaltschaft will Informationen
von einem älteren Ehepaar die fühlen
sich verdächtigt
wir wollen nirgendwohin wir sind nicht
geflohen wir wollen hier in unserem Land
leben und ich will genauso hier in
meinem Land leben antwortete Ermittler
das Misstrauen hat sich weit verbreitet
in dem kleinen Ort wie in so vielen
befreiten Gebieten werden die Menschen
auch hier erst wieder zueinander finden
müssen
weil Russland immer weniger Gas liefert
sind die Preise explodiert das macht
schon jetzt vielen schwer zu schaffen
und der Winter kommt erst noch beim
EU-Gipfel in Prag forderten deshalb
Mitgliedsländer wie Frankreich einen
EU-weiten gaspreisdeckel doch
Deutschland sträubt sich und muss sich
wegen seines 200 Milliarden Pakets
Egoismus vorhalten lassen Britta Hilpert
berichtet
sie wollen Einigkeit und Tatkraft zeigen
Deutschland Frankreich und die
Niederlande denn es tut Not der Weg aus
der Energiekrise ist schwierig es gibt
Streit vor allem um den deutschen
Bundeskanzler er bremst bei einem
gaspreisdeckel er drückt mit rund 200
Milliarden nur im eigenen Land die
Energiepreise so der Vorwurf das machen
auch andere mein Scholz und für Krisen
sei ja noch Geld da aus dem großen next
generation EU-Programm dass wir während
der deutschen EU-Ratspräsidentschaft
gemeinsam beschlossen haben sind
bislangt ist ein Fünftel der Mittel
ausgezahlt hier stehen also noch 600
Milliarden Euro zu Krisenbewältigung zur
Verfügung doch schnell kann das Geld
nicht in die neue Krise gehen der
deutsche doppelwumms von 200 Milliarden
hat viele hier geärgert das schade nicht
nur der polnischen Wirtschaft meint
Premierminister morawiecki und
appelliert an Deutschland
wie Solidarität solidarisch mit anderen
denn in schwierigen Zeiten muss man
nicht nur für sich man für alle einen
gemeinsamen Nenner finden
Prag ist der Anfang einer vielleicht
zehn Debatte um den Gaspreis Deckel die
Idee die EU sollen nicht mehr als einen
festgesetzten Preis bezahlen die Gefahr
das Gas wird woanders gekauft und fehlt
dann in der EU deshalb ist Scholz
dagegen er meint mehr Erfolg hätte eine
Einkaufsgemeinschaft von EU und
vielleicht sogar Japan und Korea das
braucht aber Zeit die keiner hat schon
in zwei Wochen wollen Sie beim nächsten
Gipfel Beschlüsse fassen denn es muss
schnell gehen der Winter steht vor der
Tür mag man auch in Prag
fragen wir Ulf Röller der in Prag dabei
ist hat der Bundeskanzler mit seinen
Vorschlägen Boden gut machen können
er steht ja heftig in der Kritik Olaf
Scholz der Bundeskanzler und ich glaube
deswegen hat er auch diese zwei
Vorschläge gemacht um zu zeigen dass die
Deutschen nicht blockieren sondern
wirklich versuchen eine Lösung zu finden
er hat einmal wie gesagt diese
superkäufe Allianz ins Spiel gebracht
eben nicht in Europa dass seine
Marktmacht einsetzt sondern auch Asien
Japan und Südkorea er hat gesagt dass er
da auch schon mal Gespräche geführt hat
ob das wirklich schnell umzusetzen ist
da waren doch hier sehr sehr viele sehr
sehr kritisch und die andere Sache ist
eben diese 600 Milliarden die aus diesem
corona-krisenfond noch übrig sind die
könnte man einsetzen für förtschaftlich
schwächere Länder und da ist Scholz
durchaus bereit mitzumachen das fanden
viele interessant das liegt jetzt auf
dem Tisch wird von den Beamten
bearbeitet weil viele Probleme liegen im
Detail und dann wird man sehen ob das
ein 14 Tagen so gut ist dass es zu einer
Einigung kommt weil wie gesagt die Zeit
drängt und in 14 Tagen will man das
beschließen
Dankeschön für diese Information vom
EU-Gipfel Dankeschön ultra
damit zu den deutschen Gaspreisen dort
soll der Anstieg möglichst schnell
spürbar gebremst werden wie genau dazu
will die zuständige Kommission bis
Montag einen Vorschlag machen eine
Entlastung greift bereits wer sich
Erdgas oder Fernwärme liefern lässt
zahlt statt 19 künftig 7% Mehrwertsteuer
das gilt rückwirkend ab diesem Monat bis
Ende März 2024 der Bundesrat hat die
Senkung heute endgültig beschlossen
übermorgen ist Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen sie könnte zum
Stimmungstest für die Ampelkoalition in
Berlin werden aber auch die hohen
Energie- und Lebensmittelpreise sind
großes Thema im aktuellen ZDF
Politbarometer liegt die SPD von
Ministerpräsident weil deutlich vor
ihrem Koalitionspartner CDU grüne und
AFD sind so stark wie nie Elisabeth
Schmidt
noch läuft der Herausforderer dem
Amtsinhaber in Umfragen hinterher Bernd
Althusmann CDU derzeit
Wirtschaftsminister liegt hinter
Ministerpräsident Stefan weil wäre heute
schon Landtagswahl käme weiß SPD auf 33%
der jetzige Koalitionspartner CDU auf 28
die Grünen 16 Prozent die FDP muss mit
5% um den Einzug in den Landtag bangen
anders die niedersächsische AFD die mit
10% ihr bislang bestes Ergebnis erzielen
könnte die Linke würde den Einzug ins
Parlament erneut verpassen die SPD von
Ministerpräsident weil wäre demnach mit
einigem Abstand stärkste Partei und
könnte sich aussuchen ob sie weiter
regieren will mit der CDU oder
umschwenkt auf ein Bündnis mit den
Grünen die gegenüber der letzten Wahl
stark zulegen der alte soll auch der
neue Regierungschef sein sagt mehr als
die Hälfte der Befragten weil liegt
deutlich vor Althusmann es wird ein
krisenmanagerjob der Wahlkampf geprägt
von Energie und Preiskrise doch die
Menschen im Land treiben auch weitere
Themen um Schule Kindergärten auch vor
allem die Plätze für im Kindergarten
Umweltschutz
politische Stabilität ganz wichtig finde
ich dass die Versorgung in den
Krankenhäusern für mich überhaupt nicht
mehr gewährleistet ist welche Parteien
in den Landtag in Hannover einziehen
bleibt bis zum Schluss spannend denn
knapp 40 Prozent sind noch unentschieden
wen sie wählen sollen am Sonntag
entscheidet Niedersachsen wer den Sprung
schafft
es ist Herbst und damit Auftakt der
üblichen krankheitssaison in
Kindergarten Schulen oder bei der Arbeit
wird vermehrt geschnieft und gehustet
erste Grippefälle gibt es schon plus
natürlich vermehrt Corona die
Krankenhäuser spüren das gleich doppelt
für immer mehr schwer erkrankte steht
immer weniger Personal zur Verfügung
auch in München wo am Montag das
Oktoberfest zu Ende ging Patricia
Schäfer berichtet
in München ist es keine Überraschung die
corona-incidenz liegt seit heute wieder
über 1.000 aber auch andere Landkreise
in Bayern und ganz Deutschland warten
mit vierstelligen Inzidenzen auf auf den
Straßen spürt man davon nichts anders in
den Krankenhäusern in Deutschlands
zweitgrößtem Klinikum dem der LMU in
München fallen derzeit 500 Mitarbeiter
Corona bedingt aus das führt zu
bettenschließungen ganze Stationen
können teilweise nicht mehr versorgt
werden und zum anderen haben wir das
Problem der steigenden Fallzahlen bei
den Patienten zunehmend Patienten die in
die Notaufnahme mit Corona kommen und
wir müssen einzelne Patienten auch nach
Hause schicken obwohl wir sie lieber im
Krankenhaus behandeln würden und die
Dynamik nimmt zu im Lauf dieser Woche
hat sich die Zahl der mit Corona
eingelieferten Patienten am lmu-klinikum
verdoppelt zwar liegen nur wenige von
ihnen auf den Intensivstationen aber auf
der normalstationen werden die Betten
knapp
das deckt sich mit der Entwicklung in
allen anderen Kliniken in München und
Umgebung der Anstieg in zeitlicher Nähe
zum Oktoberfest überrascht Mediziner
nicht die sieben Tage Inzidenz für
München hat heute die Tausender Marke
überschritten über die Notaufnahmen
können teilweise nur absolute Notfälle
stationär aufgenommen werden und die
Zahlen werden noch steigen aktuell sind
wir am Anstieg der Welle im März haben
wir diese Bettenbelegung auf dem
Höhepunkt der Welle gesehen Corona ist
keine tödliche Bedrohung mehr für die
meisten aber es bleibt lebensbedrohlich
für die Schwächeren unter uns
er ist 1930 geboren musste als
Hitlerjunge im Krieg kämpfen ging nicht
länger als vier Jahre zur Schule Günter
Lamprecht hatte keinen guten Start ins
Leben vielleicht machte ihn genau das zu
einem herausragenden Schauspieler
berühmt geworden in fassbinderfilmen
vielfach ausgezeichnet immer am Boden
geblieben mit 92 Jahren ist Günter
Lamprecht gestorben Heiko Rahms erinnert
sie haben eine Frage immer noch nicht
beantwortet wo haben sie am Behrendt auf
ihn gebracht Herr Böhnke ob als Berliner
Tatort Kommissar Markowitz oder als
Schauspieler auf der Bühne Günther
Lamprecht gehörte zu den ganz großen
Charakterdarstellern in Deutschland der
im Januar 1930 geborene Berliner spielte
meistens von Schicksal und Gewalt
gezeichnete ein Milieu das ihn schon als
Kind prägte wenn ich dran denke dass ich
mit Gewalt groß geworden bin in der
Familie dann in dem Krieg dann bei den
Nazis im Krieg und später auch in einer
Ausbildung
beruflich und so weiter dann
also ich kann Gewalt nicht ertragen
unter den über 150 Film und
Fernsehproduktionen brachte der Franz
Biberkopf in Fassbinders Berlin
Alexanderplatz international den
Durchbruch und alle wichtigen
darstellerpreise
abgefahren
der Tod im wirklichen Leben begegnete
ihm 1999 in Bad Reichenhall ein
Amokschütze verletzte ihn und seine
Lebensgefährtin schwer eine traumatische
Erfahrung bin glücklich und dankbar dass
ich also
ja jeden Morgen aus dem Fenster gucken
freue mich das Leben ist so einfach so
einfach ja nicht viel ist nicht viel
aber es ist schön
in seiner Autobiografie verarbeitete er
das Erlebte für sein Lebenswerk wurde er
mit dem Bundesverdienstkreuz erster
Klasse ausgezeichnet Lamprecht wird als
einer der größten deutschen Schauspieler
in seinen Filmen und Büchern weiterleben
[Musik]
ja jetzt zum legendären Ironman bzw iron
women wäre schön wenn es schon so
offiziell wäre immer wieder spektakulär
was jeder leisten absolut ich sag immer
ganz einfach es ist Wahnsinn 3,8
Kilometer Schwimmen 180 km auf dem Rad
und ein Marathon völlig ausgepowert aber
überglücklich freute sich die deutsche
Titelverteidigerin Anne Hauck nach mehr
als achteinhalb Stunden diesmal über
Platz 3
achteinhalb Minuten Rückstand auf die
Siegerin Anne Haug ist als Dritte im
Ziel 8 Stunden zuvor greift die
Weltmeisterin von 2019 aus Bayreuth nach
gut vier Kilometern im Pazifik mit
Tuchfühlung zur Spitze zum Rad 180
Kilometer folgen bei denen mit Favoriten
Laura Philipp aus Karlsruhe wegen
Windschatten Fahrens eine Zeitstrafe
erhält sie wird am Ende vierte Hawaii
Neuling Chelsea USA gewinnt nach dem
Marathon in 8 Stunden 33 Minuten vor der
Britin Lucy Charles Barclay Hauck fehlen
45 Sekunden zu Silber
gegeben hat da muss man mit dem
zufrieden sein was man bekommen hat und
ich bin super happy
Arne Haug steht damit nach ihrer vierten
hawaii-teilnahme zum vierten Mal auf dem
Podest
zwei deutsche Erfolge in der Fußball
Europa League Freiburg behauptet mit dem
2:0 gegen den FC North seine
Spitzenposition und bei Union Berlin
wurde der erste Sieg auf europäischer
Bühne 1:0 im schwedischen Malmö durch
die hässlichen Fanausschreitungen auf
der Tribüne getrübt das Spiel musste in
der zweiten Halbzeit knapp 30 Minuten
unterbrochen werden es droht eine Strafe
durch die UEFA
voller Zuversicht gehen die deutschen
Fußballerinnen am Abend ins
Testländerspiel gegen Frankreich das
Team von Bundestrainerin Martina Forst
Tecklenburg setzt dabei vor fast
ausverkaufte Kulisse in Dresden auf die
beiden Torjägerinnen Alexandra Popp und
Lea Schüller
tolle Aufholjagd der deutschen
Tischtennisspieler bei der
Mannschafts-WM Cheng durch China sie
drehten gegen die Franzosen ihren 0:2
Rückstand in einen drei zu zwei Sieg und
haben eine Medaille sicher im Halbfinale
wartet morgen Südkorea
ihr Halbfinale verloren haben bereits
die Deutschen tischtennis-frauen gegen
Japan mit 0:3 das Ergebnis hört sich
klar an aber Nina Mittel haben im ersten
und auch Chang Chow nach hier im dritten
Einzel sind nah dran an einem deutschen
Punktgewinn am Ende verlieren beide mit
zwei zu drei Sätzen die deutschen Frauen
dürfen sich trotzdem über Bronze freuen
der ersten WM team-medaille seit 2010
Japan spielt morgen um Gold gegen China
Asiatinnen unter sich so viel vielen
Dank vom Sport so viel und wir fragen
uns was kann passieren wenn Sie Ihr Kind
überall herum malen lassen das hier zum
Beispiel der Spross wird Künstler nennt
sich Mister Doodle und nimmt sich ein
ganzes Haus vor zwei Jahre lang
kritzelte sich der Engländer durch jeden
Raum jetzt will Mister Doodle übrigens
Englisch für kritzeln samtfrau einziehen
wir wünschen harmonische Träume
morgen wird's wettermäßig eher
durchwachsen mit Regen und vereinzelt
Gewittern der Sonntag wird dann wieder
netter Details hat gleich Katja
horneffer das heute journal um 10 mit
Marietta Slomka das komplette heute Team
dankt für Ihr Interesse und wünscht
Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend programmgemäß haben sich
Nebel und Hochnebel heute hier in
Süddeutschland länger gehalten für viele
war das wieder ein goldener Oktobertag
mit viel Sonnenschein das wird sich
ändern und das sehen Sie schon an diesen
dichteren Wolken hier bei der Nordsee
die hängen zusammen mit einer Kaltfront
und die überquert uns morgen von
Nordwest nach Südost das ist aber wieder
nur eine vorübergehende Angelegenheit
schon am Sonntag übernimmt hochvangelis
und das bedeutet dann wieder goldenes
Oktoberwetter heute Nacht beginnt es an
der Nordseeküste zu regnen und auch aus
der Schweiz heraus in der zweiten
Nachthälfte einige Regenfälle zu
erwarten südlich der Donau bildet sich
die karnebel sonst ist es mal mehr mal
weniger stark bewirken wenn es klar ist
sinken die Temperaturen auf sechs bis
vier Grad sonst bleibt es bei 12 bis 7
Grad milder die Höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen zwischen 14 Grad im
Sauerland und 19 Grad am Oberrhein und
das wird ein eher wechselhafter Samstag
mit kräftigen Regenschauern auch mal
Gewittern wie zum Beispiel Nordfriesland
und am längsten regnen wird es wohl am
Alpenrand im nördlichen
Baden-Württemberg im Süd in Hessen in
Rheinland-Pfalz und dem Saarland wird es
morgen wohl am freundlichsten sein da
gewürzt wohl kaum Regenschauer geben der
Sonntag gibt dann goldenes Oktoberwetter
nach Nebel gibt es also wieder viel
Sonnenschein etwas durchwachsener
startet die neue Woche schönes
Wochenende